voilà merci d'avoir accepté de répondre
à nos questions d'eric sur rt france
alors pour commencer sur quelle base
légale
aujourd'hui les forces de l'ordre
utilisent tel un drone pour contrôler
les comportements des citoyens alors la
france a été un des premiers pays à
mettre en place des réglementations sur
les drones et aujourd'hui la
réglementation applicable par une boîte
de 116 de 2016 c'est un arrêté de 2015
et sur le fondement de cet arrêté de
2015 les forces de l'ordre ont la
possibilité d'utiliser en dérogation aux
règles normales d'utilisation d'un drone
au dessus d'une foule ou de surveillance
des personnes auront tout à fait la
possibilité de déroger à cette
interdiction pour utiliser à des fins de
protection civile
là les drones dont c'était hier aux 900
personnes à bord
donc pour des fins de qui sont
complètement compatibles avec celles qui
leur sont assumés aujourd'hui par là par
la crise la crise du coronavirus alors
c'est pas indiquer tout à fait comme ça
dans l'arrêté est bien évidemment c'est
pour ça qu'on parle de flou juridique
aujourd'hui on va dire que grosso modo
c'est pas illégal pour la police ou la
gendarmerie d'utiliser des drones
d'ailleurs il est il utilise de manière
déjà régulière pour faire de la
surveillance de route notamment pour la
gendarmerie pour surveillance de
chauffards sur l'autoroute
donc là aujourd'hui on s'aperçoit que
beaucoup de municipalités se sont aidés
donc police municipale mais également
police nationale et gendarmerie utilise
des drones pour ré faire respecter le
confinement et utilisent ces appareils
un couplé avec des caméras alors ça peut
être des caméras thermiques ça peut être
des caméras des différents différents
types de de surveillance mais également
des haut parleurs et ses haut-parleurs
vont pouvoir donc donner des messages d
alerte de 2 attention vous êtes dans que
vous devriez être confiné rentrez chez
vous donc là c est notamment à lyon j'ai
lu que la municipalité de lyon l'avait
l'avait mis en place depuis depuis ce
matin à paris ça existe déjà depuis le
mi mars donc pas de pas de règles
définies d'interdiction ou
d'autorisation pour les forces de police
ils peuvent le faire maintenant ça
gagnerait quand même être à être par
exemple
par exemple est ce que légalement dans
le contexte de l'état d'urgence un
individu peut être verbalisé par exemple
à partir d'une constatation établi à
l'aide d'un drone par exemple
non-respect de confinement à ce qu'il
peut avoir une amende si il est vu par
le drone alors le drone va servir
d'appui aux forces au sol le drone va
servir à identifier quelqu'un qui est or
dans une zone interdite ou dans une zone
on le voit par exemple faire du vélo or
or delà de la réglementation donc avant
entre 10h et 19h une activité sportive
qui n'a pas le droit de faire
normalement
le drone va leur père et dont une zone
plus ou moins urbanisées ou en rase
campagne et va donner l'information au
sol et là on va avoir une brigade d'aidé
gendarmes ou des policiers qui vont
venir cueillir le contrevenant est là
lui mettre une lui mettre la
contravention
donc le drone en lui même pour le moment
n'utilise pas ce type de contraventions
on va dire valve a utilisé une
reconnaissance faciale qu'on pourrait
imaginer un identifier une personne au
sol et va ensuite automatiquement lui
envoyer une contravention via via un
logiciel à son domicile lorsqu'il
lorsqu'il rentre chez lui il aurait déjà
les contraventions pour pour cette cette
infraction aux règles du confinement
donc là on a aujourd'hui simplement une
surveillance aérienne on n'a pas une
engin verbalisateur alors vous le disiez
pour le moment du coup après le
confinement est ce que l' équilibre
entre la liberté et la sécurité
justement pourrait pourrait-il être mise
à mal selon vous c'est tout le problème
mais oui moi je mange de la cre âge je
fais partie de ceux qui sont très longs
bien évidemment on doit utiliser un
certain nombre de deux sur l'appel des
coraux de korn optique des moyens donc
de surveillance pendant la période de
co2 coronavirus donc ça soit les
applications stock co lead ce que ce
soit donc les drones que ce soit d'autre
d'autres systèmes pour enrayer
l'épidémie donc très bien
maintenant le risque et on l'a vu déjà
dans le passé avec les idées d'urgence
qui se sont prolongées après que l'état
lui même et et et et a été terminé
on a vu des dispositions dont certaines
extrêmement peu scrupuleuse des des du
respect de la de la vie privée des
individus rentrer dans le droit commun
et ce dont on a peur c'est qu'on a vu
fleurir des ordonnances on a vu fleurir
des décrets et arrêtés comme d'aucuns
l'ont qualifiée de liberticide et qui
aujourd'hui en tout cas contraignent
largement les individus dans leurs
déplacements et dans le respect de leur
vie privée
est-ce qu'il ne la tentation ne serait
pas de pouvoir éventuellement les
projets dans l'avenir en tout cas la
cnil a bien évidemment indiqué qu'elle
allait être extrêmement attentive à ce
type de de dérive si elle devait
intervenir on n'ose le croire mais
sait-on jamais on a déjà eu des cas dans
le passé
pas si facile éloigné de d'état
d'urgence qui se prolongeait dans l'est
dans les textes donc oui à une certaine
crainte est aujourd'hui la technologie
étant ce qu'elle est on a parlé beaucoup
de l'application stop qu'ovide qui est
l'application qui permettrait de pouvoir
permettre aux gens alors avait sur la
base d'un consentement sur la base du
volontariat nous dit on en attendre
latent de devoir de pouvoir savoir si
elles ont été ou non en contact avec des
personnes contaminées mère se voit là
merci merci beaucoup
thierry vallat d'avoir rendu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat au barreau de paris